[Music]
chris and i seem to agree that for
carson wentz it really is a boomer bus
proposition for 2019 in large part based
upon his ability to stay healthy if he's
healthy he will be great the eagles will
be great he could be the mvp and the
eagles could win their second super bowl
in three years if he gets injured who
the heck knows what happens and how much
will the eagles be regretting all that
money they have paid once so he is the
poster child for our boomer bus draft
and let's just agree let's stipulate he
can't be picked right he's the
inspiration for it
no carson wentz yep all right because
that's good because you were gonna win
the coin toss and you would have taken
him so i like that that's a win for me
already go ahead heads or tails go ahead
legitimate fair even-handed coin toss
let's see what you got oh gosh i don't
know where to go here it's been heads
for two days in a row i don't know if
she wants to go that way i'm gonna go
heads again i don't think she's gonna
actually think i'd pick heads for a
third day in a row
oh darn it all right go ahead
all right well you know what and this is
one of those days where there isn't
whenever you figure it out
get out i figured out the psychology of
the rigged coin toss i'm going to start
with a team that right now we would
assume is going to be in bust category
because they haven't been to the
playoffs in a very long time but the
tampa bay buccaneers to me are the
ultimate boomer bus proposition for
2019. there are plenty of players
coaches teams we could throw into this
category i think without question the
bucks under bruce arians this is either
going to work and it is going to work
incredibly well yeah or it's just going
to be
same old buccaneers hello five and 11 4
and 12. and jameis winston's gone and
who knows how long bruce arians remains
as the head coach but if anybody can
stir a team quickly and move a team from
worst to first it's bruce arians and you
know i'm i'm i'm rooting for boom yeah
i'm preparing for bust but i don't see
any in between and after he got that job
somebody in the nose said to me this is
either going to be spectacular right for
the bucks or it's going to be a total
disaster that seems to be the sentiment
around the nfl whenever i've talked to
people in the league too about the tampa
bay buccaneers and i think it's a good
pick by you mike i mean yeah i could see
them you know somehow maybe being
competitive sneaking into the playoffs
jameis winston has a career year and
throws 35 touchdowns and 4 800 yards and
we go oh my gosh i could also see it
going whoa this is an absolute disaster
jameis winston's thrown 22 interceptions
bruce arians is getting redder than the
buccaneers red on their jerseys and you
know things are horrible and they're
four and 12. i i'm with you i can see it
going either way i'm rooting for boom as
well i'd like to see it work did you
want to say something no sorry that was
not your finger pointing okay i thought
you were giving me
i should be doing this you're well done
thank you yeah you're agreeing with me
well yeah i'm not always a jerk and
always disagree with you when you make a
good pick at least i admit it from time
to time but i never do i know you don't
rodgers and lefleur green bay packers
boom or bust i don't care what you put
up there guys in the back room maybe
rogers and lefleur is what we want to
put up there but to me
little floor and rogers that's our song
yesterday nobody even knows what we're
talking about but either way okay i look
at this and go aaron rodgers he could
win the mvp this year it could set up to
where oh they've improved that defense
oh it's matt lefleur in as the head
coach nate hackett is the offensive
coordinator they're gonna formulate all
these new things and he's gonna have
these plays that he's never had in his
career and it's all gonna be great and
man rogers throws 40 touchdowns and five
interceptions and he's the mvp and the
packers are what top one of the top
seeds in the nfc playoffs i could also
see it going oh week four there's
problems in green bay aaron rodgers
doesn't like the offense or we start to
hear about you know lafleur and nate
hackett are talking about aaron rodgers
is you know not liking some of the plays
or the game plans and things like that
and they're seven and nine and don't
make the playoffs so they're six and ten
or something like that i think it will
be more boom but i certainly think there
is a bust factor here because you know i
think lefleur is an unproven commodity
as far as a head coach to this point and
you know hey we got to see aaron rodgers
work with somebody else other than mike
mccarthy
yeah now the thing though is and and i'm
not i'm not doing this to be a jerk yeah
the challenge with all these picks right
because really you could make any
proposition any team any coach any
player and say there's boomer bust
potential the question is how big is the
middle ground yeah right and and with
rogers on the floor there's a middle
ground there i don't know how big it is
but there is a middle ground where it's
like well okay it wasn't great but it
wasn't horrible and there are some signs
there that for 2020 it can all move in
the right right direction i don't think
it's a huge middle ground so i'm kind of
agreeing with you that it is more boom
or bust than it is well okay so far so
good right um and i mention all that
because my next pick is clear boom or
bust there is no middle ground if it's
not boom it's going to be regarded as
bust and that's todd gurley uh todd
gurley's either going to be back to the
guy that he was in 2017 or he's going to
be a guy that has
500 rushing yards and
it doesn't have you know
much involvement in the offense i mean
it's either going to be he is great or
it's a bust and because he set the bar
so high a couple of years ago he's got
to either come come
close to or surpass that barrier or it's
going to be regarded as a bust because
we're going to be watching every game
every week is he playing as much as he
has in the past is he producing the way
he has in the past is he showing up on
the injury report how much is daryl
henderson being used the rookie third
rounder out of memphis so i don't think
there's much middle ground there it's
either going to be boom
and we're going to say hey todd gurley
is still todd gurley or bust todd gurley
is no longer todd gurley and i do not
see a middle ground yeah i don't know if
i see a middle i i guess where uh yeah i
don't know where the middle ground is
there either that's my question about
that situation you're i think that's you
know the good way to sum it up because
yeah i don't know i don't expect the
boom to be as
boomlicious as it's been in years past
okay then it's bust yeah that's the
right thing right if you're not because
most people aren't paying attention to
it the way that we are and the way that
people who watch this show are where
we're very conscious and cognizant of
the issues with todd gurley's knee if
todd gurley has less than a thousand
rushing yards people are going to say
that's a horrible season yeah yeah right
right if he if he's not the top fantasy
running back because there's going to be
people who have him penciled in number
one yeah right oh hey we got to have
todd gurley no no no so if they're
expecting 1500 yards from scrimmage and
15 total touchdowns and they don't get
it it's going to be a bust that's the
concern for most people the bar is still
high for those of us who have been
paying attention to this the bar should
be lower the problem is for most people
it's going to be regarded as a bust yeah
doesn't meet that very high bar no i
agree i think that's where i kind of
felt with like rogers and lafleur like
they could be nine and seven and not get
in the playoffs and people are just
gonna go oh that's a bust that's a bust
and yeah i'm with you there mike you're
right i think that will be the overall
perceived notion on todd gurley and
definitely one of the most interesting
stories of 2019. all right i'm going to
go since you picked a player i'm going
to go with you on the a player pick here
lamar jackson boomer bust 20 or 9 20 19.
he's at the top of the list for me mike
i mean yes
i could see okay the baltimore ravens
they've added more run plays and more
run game design around lamar jackson and
he got better
at the passing game and decision making
and you know more accurate and big time
throws that way and i go ooh that i mean
that if that happens boom the baltimore
ravens are a super bowl contender but i
can easily sit here and go oh you know i
could certainly think of the other side
of the coin and go
man what we saw last year was a lot of
inconsistencies in throwing the football
and gosh you know it could be just a
total disaster and teams have caught on
to what they're trying to do offensively
in the run game and then he on top of
that is not developing as the pocket
passer that we'd like and it becomes
total bust bill to where you know i'd
worry about rg3 sitting behind him i
mean i really could see it going both
ways to where baltimore could win the
division and be a top three seed in the
afc playoffs or you know they fall off
the earth and the pass game just can't
keep keep up with uh the times and what
they need to do and they're not in the
playoffs at all
and i agree with you completely on that
because the expectations will be there
for jackson to be the guy that he was at
louisville
and you know i think he's gonna have a
hard time staying healthy which puts him
into that same bust category that carson
wentz i mean basically he's the afc
version of carson wentz yeah even though
he doesn't have the track record of
being injured he's going to be exposed
if he runs the ball and i know that
steve bashady the owner of the ravens
said he's not going to run the ball 20
times a game i mean that's encouraging
you never expect a quarterback to do
that the question becomes how much will
he run how much will he get hit and will
he get injured and will that be rg3 time
in baltimore if lamar jackson can't
continue so i agree with you both on how
good is he going to be and how healthy
is he going to be there's real boomer
bust potential for lamar jackson all
right i'm going to stay in the division
but i'm taking a coach and
a year ago if you had asked me to map
out the 100
most likely coaching candidates for 2019
i wouldn't have had freddy kitchens on
the list i i because i would have like
wait a minute a guy who was offensive
coordinator got demoted to running backs
coach or no he was quarterback's coach
and got demoted running back to coach
excuse me in arizona then he's running
backs coached with the browns and you
know if the browns are good hue jackson
will still be the coach how did the
dominoes fall that freddie kitchens ends
up being the head coach anywhere yeah
starting the year as running backs coach
in cleveland i never would have had him
on that list and here he is as the head
coach of the browns he's earned that
opportunity but with all the
expectations all the pressure with all
the scrutiny
it's all going to be on him and this
team's either going to deliver a playoff
spot or it's not and if it doesn't it's
his fault and if it does he he's not
going to get any credit they were
supposed to right he's in a no-win
situation here yes freddie kitchens
how does he you know i always say coach
of the year is the guy who most exceeds
expectations
i don't know how you can exceed
expectations if your freddie kitchens
are expecting you to win the division
you're right so i it's it's it's boomer
bust and the boom is presumed and the
bust is looming and if they don't make
it to the playoffs he's going to be
regarded as a failure yeah you're right
there doesn't seem like there's a lot of
uh room for like the boom factor where
guys are yeah everyone's expecting good
things and a drastic turnaround and yeah
i think if it's anything but that people
are gonna go oh it's a bust so i'm not
mad at you here i mean none of these are
bad picks so i'm not gonna fight hard
there's so many good ones to pick from
here that's the interesting thing but
the browns is come on this is must watch
tv this year certainly be one of those
teams on a sunday i'm always gonna keep
my eye on because of the players the
personalities yeah the first year head
coach all of those things who knows
which way it goes so i'm with you there
mike not a bad pick now this is where i
mean i don't know where to go here you
know i thought about you know big ben
and the steelers right uh how about the
bears kicker situation i think about
that but i'm damn i'm not picking
kickers for a draft the hell with that
okay you know eli manning jason garrett
shanahan garoppolo i'm thinking of all
but i'm gonna go one that is close to
the heart of mike florio
your purple little heart
your purple little heart and yes i'm
gonna go with kirk cousins i think he
fits the mold here i don't like actually
picking them because it just
lets this narrative continue to feed why
did you pick it well because
it is the narrative and that i can't
avoid that and as much as i want to try
to change it and and get people against
it you know perception is reality in the
nfl i learned that and it's just it is
that's the way it is and the perception
of the kirk cousins is right now is hey
you got paid a lot of money to come here
and bring us to a super bowl and bring
us to the playoffs and in year one we
didn't do as good as we did with the
year we just before where where we had
you so i look at this year to go like
you know yeah the boom factor is they
have to make the playoffs the bus factor
is if they don't make the playoffs it's
a bust it's it's literally that it's
gonna be oh we didn't make the playoffs
why are we paying you 27 million dollars
a year gosh we went to the final four
with case keenum what are we doing and
i'm not so sure if they don't have a
great year and don't make the playoffs
that they might not think about you know
doing something with kirk cousins at the
quarterback situation we've talked about
it you know
you know if the 49ers and jimmy
garoppolo didn't play well and you know
the vikings decided they were sick of
kirk cousins would they go there would
kirk cousins end up in you know the
49ers or the rams with sean mcvay you
know there's so many possibilities there
but i think it's the ultimate
guy
chris sims pick kirk cousins not me and
chris sims is the one that is
propagating today the notion of kirk
cousins being traded to the 49ers
tattletail you tattletail i've got the i
just want to make sure we know whose
voice is whose i've got the bucks todd
gurley freddie kitchen sims has rogers
and lefleur lamar jackson and kirk
cousins we'll be back more pfd live
right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports